two men are dead and another hurt after
a shooting in the northwest valley eight
news now was first to bring you this
breaking news at six o'clock it happened
just off the 95 near centennial parkway
and tropical that's where we find
madison kimbrough live with more on this
ongoing active investigation
metro police received reports of gunfire
just before 4 30 this afternoon right
down this street and around the corner
on glowing ember court when they arrived
on scene they found a man in his 20's
dead in front of a house once police
entered the home they found another man
who had been shot he died on scene not
long after a man walked into centennial
hospital with gunshot wounds he was
found to be involved in this case he's
now at umc and is expected to survive
metro police stating that all the
individuals involved knew each other
all these subjects were inside of a
residence and while they were inside of
a residence there was an altercation
during that altercation there was an
exchange of gunfire
where the the two decedents
uh were struck
we also believe during that same volley
of gunfire is when the
the victim who is at the hospital was
struck by gunfire
police stating that they currently have
two people detained and don't believe
anyone related to this incident is on
the loose neighbors in the area have
been able to access their homes now it's
still unknown what led up to this
shooting but metro will continue to be
on scene for the foreseeable future for
the next couple hours reporting live in
centennial hills madison kimbrough live
local now